[Music]
on the last item on the agenda of the
disinformation, we had an
intensive exchange about the individual
measures that the countries have already taken at
member level, since,
for example, Germany with the
network enforcement law association
Reich should also be mentioned here and we are
also trying ours in Austria
to take an example and see what
can be done here at the national
level that's why it's so important to
initiate the debate in this regard
people serious this here before a
world priest minister dr double
computers and in new york for kastrati
score is the quality document of the eu
cooperation comments chance  once
again calls to mind the
european team, so to speak, sport is
definitely on the right track with a contribution of 2 67 percent of the european team
austria has six percent of
the gross domestic product when it comes to
sport as a contribution to the budget europe
and i were not only  the largest part of
the greatest pan-european event in the
history of sports holding thonemann
involve different european cities will
contribute to death and objectives
european integration mobility solutions
[music]